[Musik]
in köln
das ist die findet alle zwei jahre statt
ich habe auch schon ein video gemacht
und heute sonntag heute ist mein großer
tag denn gleich wenn ich oben auf der
bühne in der show beginn der kuckuck
themen küche zwei stunden lang kochen
und backen und ich glaube sind schon
ganz viele zuschauer da
hat
[Musik]
packungen sie gleich töten dann hinten
rein wir haben wir packen heute wechseln
töten
für meine zuschauer die wir kommen
wieder los alle die wir auf der messe
finden und dafür möchte ich mich auch
fernsten fertig war meine sponsoren
bedanken die mir alle pro geschickt
haben
da wären zum beispiel gar eco park küche
im keller sachen auf meinem eigenen shop
sind mit drinnen und globus erfüllt
folklore finger mit drin und die packen
wir so fertig die autogrammkarten kommen
mit rein und dann geht es gleich mit und
zu hoffen
[Musik]
angenommen
warum normal
ja auch im erklärung habe ich ja auch
mal bei mir machen
eine mitgemacht haben
[Musik]
mein großer tag denn gleich wenn ich
oben auf der bühne in der show begin der
cooking clemens küche drei stunden lang
kochen und backen und ich glaube sind
schon ganz viele zuschauer da und gerade
wurde mir gesagt wird ein kind oben da
hat die augen verbunden und cdu darauf
dass hat die weiß gar nicht wo sie ist
und ich glaube dass die mama sie
überraschen mittel in dem sie nichts so
kommt man mit wenig länger warten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
werden
[Musik]
eine frage die viele und mit den auftrag
wir entwickeln gerade erst hat für mich
viele programme mit dem topmodell
verwenden
[Musik]
wer könnte viele probleme haben und wir
werden vorgegeben um die aufteilung der
macht mich ganz herzlich dafür bedanken
dass ihr wirklich dabei und unsere
bedeutung und wir werden mit sicherheit
wieder auf anderen messen zu sehen und
deshalb etwas wenn ich auch wir waren
die letzten meter im rat die letzten 1
aktion in der küche einfach
weitergemacht aber
schön
[Musik]